ah I can never get I can ever I can
never win with this thing okay hey I'm
just gonna make do okay here we go
alright
okay nothing so far
nothing so far I did not die in dead
space 2 there is no flashlight
huh huh no gun no flashlight Oh
yes I'm on skype what is your question
stop yelling at me what
okay the noise stopped
I don't there's not much sound going on
right now there was oh yeah my brave
issues oh yeah I could take this this
ain't nothing you say nothing at all I
got this I got this
why am i so awesome
I don't know but a huge brain muscles
I'm just awesome with the ladies like
crazy amounts of sex all the time every
day yeah that's why I'm so awesome yeah
born in the lip of a volcano in Hawaii
yeah
punched I punch trees down with my fists
I've said before I built my room every
single day or every week or so whatever
get bored of it I punch a new tree
chopping into blanks and then just ten
I'm on floor ten and then I make a new
by me
there's nothing there
I'll hang on I messed up one second
sorry now ah I had the sound muted
because I was doing stuff before but now
the sound should be back can you hear
that
I hear breathing the me
there's no number
well way to go misspelling my name thank
you very much
there you go that's better
yeah
thank you very much 14 I think I've
heard people go down to like level 80 in
this game it's just totally random what
was that
what was that
I hear something like footsteps besides
mine
you're all gonna watch it and you're all
gonna like it you're coming down this
stairwell with me thank you
that's enough that's enough a :
because this is the game read the story
scp-087
the stairwell itself is a monster before
my honor I swear I hear footsteps
besides my own
I can't sprint in this game I'm 20 level
here that
Oh
huh
hmm it's not following me this is behind
me I can't go any faster
something was knocking I don't know what
I don't know what my level 23
Hey
oh it's too late to go up well I think I
might have heard something you can't go
up yeah you cannot go up yeah
shredder just gave the link to the
actual story behind this game it's
really interesting great read and this
is there are two versions of this game
this is the first version and there's
another version button made by the same
guy that made containment breach oh my
god 26 okay I'll get to it eventually
don't throw your kitty at my screen
don't throw your kitty out your screen
oh my god oh my god
the rumblings getting louder I swear
this either the stairwell is getting
more narrow or the field of vision is
changing huh
okay
okay it's okay
it's okay we're okay we just hit 30 just
hit level 30
okay how many of yours we got in here
just to get someone to say so
if I had a chair
forty-eight not bad
use my muscles what the heck are my
muscles gonna do game over man not yet
I have no idea I don't know what that
means but okay I'm doing okay so far I
don't know how you win this game I don't
even think you can win the game
what was that
I swear my breathing's getting louder or
something's happening something's
changing
I'll do yog box eventually
oh man
huh
oh I thought that was it I thought I
thought it was gonna get me what level
in my thirty nine three nine three nine
39 39 ha ha ha about to hit 40 ding-dong
40 huh I can do this I know I can
thank you let's wait till I get 250 if I
get 250
oh man hoodoos stairwells could be this
fun ha good guns would not help in this
situation
I don't want to do it again
okay okay okay I'm okay I'm okay I'm
okay I'm okay
oh okay I'm okay
okay
forty-five
thirty-six
the rumbling
the rumbling is still there 47
yeah always a plus he's gonna be in
great shape
48 hmm yeah it's getting louder
behind me no okay
still good still good 49
only by me I'll look behind me all I
want
oh nothing whole lot nothing fifty
ding-ding-ding-ding-ding bliley little
wing I don't know what the knocking
sound is don't ask actually six one six
is the number of the beast there's been
with some mistranslations and six one
six look it up
Kurt
ah
it's it's really not people have
mistranslated six-six-six to be the
number of the beast it's been
reciprocated that six-six-six is number
of the beast but if you go actual to the
back trent back to the translations of
early text it's really six one six
yes truly look it up
fifty-five
holy balls
okay
I don't know if it was like I don't know
if there's like something that'll kill
me after a while or what
just trying to make my way down
do my own thing
five minutes of coop yeah
oh boy
come on you monsters look at this
see this is how horror games should be
you don't ever see a monster but you
know they're there
your mind is supposed to make up the
horror for you and also this is great
design philosophy that the amnesia
creators reiterated things are supposed
to have not supposed to happen to the
character the character is supposed to
do things and that's what causes the
horror see a game that forces you to go
downstairs when you don't want to go
downstairs is scary as [ __ ] because it
won't be scary unless you do something I
didn't know even though a floor I'm on
anymore
sixty-five when did I get past 60 I
don't know I don't know
okay
I missed the light switch yeah don't go
insane here why not yeah I love going
downstairs ha ha
don't slow down a bit there
okay
oh I can jump I can jump really that's
weird I didn't know that I could jump
okay my getting shorter or something it
seemed like the handrails are getting
higher to my eye level before I go down
ah
boring
ha not scary jump over the railing can I
no no oh I can totally aah
I'm breaking the system look at me go
ha ha can't stop me now what uh got
stuck there ha ha who's enough ha huh
huh before my own 177 yeah
that's cheating huh
okay I won't break the system
Oh
I thought I saw something
Isak by a longshot okay look look what
happens see the rail is much shorter
what the hell is going on
I'm on 8080 ding ding negatively leaving
ding ding ding huh
Oh was I crouched I don't even know if
there is a Crouch button
okay I don't know if anything's actually
gonna happen or if there's an end so
let's call a shout-out a number that I
should stop at and I'll stop there or
should I just go until something happens
that secret six
hundred okay I'll get to a hundred seems
to be generally I've already said Isaac
is better than Simon
okay they seem to be okay 86 86
six
it depends on what you're looking for
cry of fear for more scares dead space
for better gameplay
I mean craw fear was a mod of course
it's not going to have the best gameplay
in the world
but it was atmospheric and terrifying
the rumbling is like super loud now
oh not scary go until I see what the
face I don't even know if the faces in
this game
ninety nine ninety ninety dingdong ten
away
I've already read the story
200 floors
well in this story there's supposedly
you can hear a girl crying down at the
bottom but at the moment
I can't see much of anything happening
floors there
I heard something new
ninety-five
no there's no red why are some of you
guys seeing things I'm not seeing
ninety-seven
looks like blood I wouldn't doubt it
I'm not doubt it
oh my gosh
okay
dead space by storyline
yay 100 I made it
oh I keep going do I try to jump down
now
Oh
what was that
whoa is that huh huh I heard some damn
it
ah damn it some reason it's not letting
me jump down anymore there we go damn it
keeps sliding me off
ah
okay I got this I got this
I can beat this game I think
I don't even know what floor I'm on hang
on let me check 109 109
all right good night guy I'm good in 110
I'm gonna go to 120 and if there's
nothing by 120 then I'll just call it
quits
I swear I would have thought that the
face would be here
do creepypasta
I thought creepypasta was just stories
that you could read
I have no stories to tell no there's no
save button
I think I think this is like the first
game but it's also the underdeveloped
game maybe maybe the other one has been
ah how's miss your face ok 120
okay
ah
ah there is a monster in this one
there's a monster where is he
ah where is he what hello okay or the
games gonna crash again why the [ __ ] is
with things crashing I didn't do
anything
I did nothing the game just ended began
just ended I died it got me there was I
totally missed it what I didn't there
was oh my god there was a monster
are you all just yanking my chain was
there actually something there was
really there was really something there
oh my godness I I was looking right at
it I didn't see a thing
are you kidding me
there was a mop oh oh yeah I'm recording
- I uh I'll check back later but oh if
that was a monster oh I didn't see
anything
oh look at right